whatever you want to whatever wherever
your spiritual views are the story of
the god of Heaven and Earth coming down
in the form of a baby and then dying for
everyone's sins and then all you have to
do is believe that story and you'll
never die is a great story right and
when you're 15 and you hear that you're
like that's a good story so I
fully 100 percent uh converted to this
very conservative brand of Evangelical
Christianity and then spread that story
to pretty much everyone I knew until
until I went to college and decided I'm
gonna study this stuff because it's so
great it's so fascinating who was the
who was a teacher that messed you up in
college
to know who was it a girlfriend or a
teacher who's a teacher I went to a
Jesuit university and it was the
Catholics that screwed me up the Jesuits
who were like oh yeah you believe that
stuff
yeah intellectual uh priesthood in in
the in the Catholic talk about Santa
Clara yeah at Santa Clara yeah well
modified Jesuits but yeah yeah like like
liberation theology Jesuits you know
that like that that hardcore uh uh
Jesuits
um they're the ones that turned you off
from Christianity it's after being such
a hardcore believer it's not that they
turned me off of Christianity it's that
they taught me the truth of the Gospel
message they they they told me about
Jesus the man instead of Jesus the
Christ right they told me about the
historical person who walked the Earth 2
000 years ago and said these things
and what the context of what he said
meant at the time and how we should read
that today as opposed to the sort of
spiritualization you know the
metaphysical aspect of the of the things
that he said the way that his incredibly
radical
revolutionary words and thoughts were
defanged by the first church and turned
into wishy-washy spiritualism or what we
now call Christianity
um they gave me an insight into
the the original idea of what he was
talking about how different are those
two ideas Jesus the man and Jesus who
became the Messiah how I mean Jesus the
Messiah has no concerns for the cares of
this world whatsoever
his only concern is you know the world
to come what does it matter what you eat
in this world and what does it matter
what you how you dress the only world
that matters is the world to come and
focus all your attention on that world
and not not the vagaries of this world
that's that's Jesus Christ
Jesus of Nazareth
was a radical revolutionary whose sole
Focus was on the suffering of the people
on this world right now and the power
structures that were creating that
suffering
the Jesus Jesus Christ is everyone's the
same we're all equal there's nothing
between rich and poor everyone's the
same
Jesus the man said
no the first shall be last and the last
shall be first the hungry will be will
be fed and those who are fed will go
hungry
right those who have will have it taken
away from them and those who don't have
will get it that's not we're all the
same that's the reversal of the social
order right that's the top and the
bottom switching places is that more of
a socialist component is that like a
Robin Hood who who would he be in a the
Jesus the man in a in a metaphoric
concept I mean I think he's got more in
common with Che Guevara than Robin Hood
I mean again Jesus at no point in any of
the gospels does Jesus talk about
everyone is equal everyone should have
the same that's not a that's not a Jesus
line right that the world that I see is
one in which everyone has the same
that's socialism the world that Jesus
talked about
quite a violent world it was a
revolutionary world and it was a world
in which the first became last and the
last became first
like that's not a that's not a popular
Viewpoint amongst you know the people in
the category of first it's it's
interesting though that they're the so
the Jesuits in Santa Clara made you look
at Jesus as the Messiah and the
individual so then you went through the
Journey there and then how did that
bring you back to Muslim well so the
kind of Evangelical Christianity that I
had ascribed to is very rigid
and at its core is this idea that the
Bible is literal and it is inerrant
and it takes 10 minutes
of research to discover that both of
those things are total [ __ ] like the
Bible is riddled with errors I mean
riddled with the most basic most obvious
contradictions and errors
um and that the idea that it should be
read literally you know makes no sense
at all and so once you start
understanding the chasm between the man
Jesus and how he became the Christ of
Christianity
it's really hard to continue to follow
the Christ of Christianity any longer
and so would you give some examples of
that by the way like the most palpable
errors that that you would just notice
immediately yeah sure so Matthew Mark
and Luke say that uh Jesus uh was
crucified on a Thursday uh and uh the
Gospel of John says it was like a Sunday
so in other words it was before the
Passover and the Gospel of John was
after the Passover
um you know Matthew uh has Jesus uh for
some strange reason going to Egypt uh
whereas Luke says has the same birth
story says nothing about Jesus um uh in
Matthew uh Jesus is born in what we
would now recognize as probably
um 10 A.D ish 8 or 10 A.D
um and in Luke Jesus is born and what we
now recognize at about 4 BC
um so
uh you know it's there's all these
contradictions it's just very obvious
clear contradictions the reason the
reason I asked that because the obvious
question is whether it's the Bible
whether it's the Torah whether it's the
Quran should these books these relics be
taken literally or metaphorically not
only should they be taken metaphorically
they were never ever ever intended to be
read literally do you think
the authors the the author of Luke
who says that uh you know in the year uh
you know but I guess it's six six or six
A.D
um there is a census in Rome and the
census requires everyone in the entire
Roman Empire
to stop what they are doing and travel
to their father's Homeland so that they
could be properly counted
um for a for the um uh taxation purposes
and so Joseph uh who lived in Nazareth
had to travel to Bethlehem in order to
be counted because his parents family
was from Bethlehem
okay
there is no census of the entire Roman
Empire in 6 A.D there's a small census
in Syria but where Jesus lived did not
Encompass that census
census law under the Roman Empire is as
clear as it gets you get counted where
you live the purpose of Sensei of a
census is taxation so we're here to
count your stuff how many people are you
and where's your stuff the idea that
every once in a while everyone in the
largest greatest richest Empire the
world had ever known would have to stop
what they were doing and travel for
months at a time to wherever their
forefathers were born in order and also
bring their stuff I guess uh in order to
be counted there is patently absurd and
unhistorical now here's the important
thing to understand about what I just
said
not only does It screw up the entire
Christmas story that you tell your kids
every day or every every Christmas
but Luke who wrote that knew that that
wasn't true he was living as a citizen
of the Roman Empire his readers for
Generations read that and knew that that
wasn't true that's not how sin the
census works I've gone through many
censuses and that's not how it works
they didn't care
because the idea the notion that what
was being read was meant to be read
literally would never have even occurred
to them
the idea that scripture is a thing to be
read historically and literally was born
of the 19th century
it's only been about a couple of hundred
years since the very notion of biblical
literalism has existed and it's existed
as a result of the Scientific Revolution
which said that a thing can only be true
if it could be demonstrably proven true
if it could be historically proven to be
true that's what true means now
that definition of true did not exist in
the ancient mind right true had nothing
to do with facts
true had a much deeper meaning the truth
of the the Nativity Story is that Jesus
was born in the city of Bethlehem
because that's the city of David and
Jesus is the new David and he is going
to recreate the kingdom of David and so
therefore he has to be born in Bethlehem
when everyone knew he was born in
Nazareth his name was the Nazarene
that's what his name was
so you know it's it's only we in the
modern world that have created this kind
of fake uh and totally unnecessary
filter
through which we force all of our
scriptures the Quran the the the the
Torah the the gospels all of our
scriptures to uh succumb to our
particular definition of what is true
without realizing that that definition
of true is barely 200 years old and are
you saying that the same rules apply to
the Torah and also the Quran All gospel
so it's all metaphorical what we call
gospels are what we refer to as sacred
history and we use that term sacred
history
specifically to differentiate it from
actual history and by the way that is
not to denigrate sacred history it's to
understand it for what it actually is
right there's a message that is being
given to us over thousands of years and
that message is important but you have
to filter out the modern conceptions of
how we understand you know facts and
truths in order to actually really get
to the heart of what that message is
last question on this
would most religious Scholars tend to
believe with what you're saying or
because I'm sure there's a large sect of
religious Scholars and people of Faith
whether it's Muslim Jewish Christian of
every sect that'll say sorry Reza this
is the literal word of God and thank you
for your opinion but I'm sticking to the
exactly what the Bible says so there's
people of faith and then there's
religious Scholars how do those two come
to terms with what you're saying well
among religious Scholars what I just
said is the most basic element like fact
number one the thing you learn on day
one right be nothing nothing else that
you do
can happen until you understand that
basic fact that it's metaphorical well
that it's sacred history right so you
can use figurative language metaphorical
language you can extract history from
sacred history there are ways that we
can do that like we can look at the
gospels and say these are the things
that are most likely to be traced to the
actual historical Jesus and these are
the things not and there are
centuries of methodologies that we can
use to rely on to get a very accurate
picture of the difference between the
two
people of Faith No no people of faith
do not think in those terms right for
people of Faith the scripture is God
breathed it's divinely inspired and if
it comes from God then it must be
perfect in all ways and so
what does historical context have to do
with it right Jesus is literally God
speaking to all Humanity so who cares
where he lived who he was actually
speaking to what the political and
economic situation of the world in which
he lived and how it shaped him what does
that matter he has no context God has no
context right okay so he just for three
decades he lived in first century
Palestine irrelevant irrelevant he's not
talking to his fellow Jews he's talking
to you and me so context has to be
stripped from scripture for it to matter
and Scholars say the opposite so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]